Thanks hey guys I'm Josh and yeah i'll
be talking about radius and diameter in
sparse graphs so a brief outline of what
I'll be talking about today I'll begin
with an overview of the radius and
diameter problems just as a quick recap
next I'll talk about the various
hardness conjectures we'll be using to
prove lower bounds for these two
problems so in this work we talked about
both upper and lower bounds and we
managed to get some of them to match so
I'll talk about what hardness conductors
we need to prove the lower bound half of
that I'll be going more briefly over our
results for truly sub quadratic
approximation in other words like how
well can you approximate these two
problems in n to the two minus epsilon
time and then I'll spend more time
trying to talk at depth about our fixed
parameters sub quadratic algorithms and
we get to that section talk I'll kind of
explain what that term means all right
so radius and diameter so some quick
definitions to begin suppose we have
graph G equals V come e and then we'll
define the distance between two nodes U
and V to be the length of the shortest
path from u to V and we'll define the
East centricity of node denoted a of V
there as the maximum distance from V to
any other node and so the radius problem
just asks what's the minimum
eccentricity of any note inside the
entire graph and that note is called the
center so it says like which node can
reach all the notes quickly and how long
does it take to reach every other node
from the center and the diamond problem
is just the maximum eccentricity but
it's really just the longest path in the
longest shortest path in the graph it's
not too hard to see that if you can
solve all pair shortest paths or apps up
you can solve this problem but apps up
kind of outputs n squared things so
there's n squared time just for
outputting the information because it
outputs the information for all pairs
and there are n things so there n
squared pairs so even when the graph is
sparse apps up will require n squared
time but rate isn't a mateur because
they just sort of output like one number
the e centricity of the minimum is
interested in actually eccentricity
maybe we could possibly do better
and in particular in this paper not only
do we study the normal undirected
definitions of radius in diameter we
have the following natural extensions
for directed graphs so sources necessity
is kind of like the undirected version
but like you only care about the case
where you want to get from V to the
other nodes in the graph round-trip
eccentricity is when you want to get to
the other node in the graph and you want
to get back to your center node V for
sources for maximum eccentricity you
care about the larger of the two
distances and the course the natural
follow-up definition is min e centricity
where you care about the smaller of the
two distances and it turns out that's
actually a pretty hard pretty hard
problem so for all of these definitions
we're still interested in the minimum
eccentricity for radius in the maximum
14 diameter so for example the source
radius problem asks what is the smallest
source eccentricity intergraph and this
leads to 7 directed problems because two
of them are actually the same if you
think about it source diameter and max
diameter or just asking you the same
thing because it doesn't matter which
way you take it for diameter alright
next I'm going to go briefly over the
hardness conjectures that we'll be using
so as everyone's probably really
familiar with the strong exponential
time hypothesis by in parklands Oh Peter
I Zayn just says there's no 2 minus
epsilon to the n algorithm for k set and
it's been used yeah well throughout not
only throughout this workshop but
throughout this quarter to prove a
variety of interesting lower bounds and
many of which show that look this
algorithm we wouldn't we weren't sure
could be improved is actually tight
specifically we will be using some more
polynomial time conjectures so before I
can list a conjecture I'll define a
problem so for the first one is the
orthogonal vectors problem which you're
probably all familiar with as well so
you're just giving two lists of n
vectors in 0 1 to the C log n and the
question is is there a pair of the
orthogonal pairs so vector a from
capital a of vector B from capital B
such that the two are orthogonal and the
orthogonal vectors conjecture just says
there's no truly sub quadratic algorithm
for this problem
so the orthogonal vectors conjecture was
actually used by Radha T and Virginia
who I don't think it's here at the
moment to show that diameter is hard so
we'll be using a different problem to
show why radius is hard and how I will
explain after I show you the next
structure why we kind of need this sort
of change in conjecture to explain why
radius is hard so here's a very related
problem it's called the heating set
existence problem so almost the same
setup you have two lists and vectors
there are C log n coordinates and you
want to know is there a vector in the
first list that is not orthogonal to any
vector in the second list in other words
is there us is there is there a vector
enlist a that hits every vector in this
b and then there's the analogous hitting
set conjecture which matches the
orthogonal vectors conjecture but just
for the hitting set existence problem
instead and the reason i put these
quantifiers up here is to explain better
why we want to move to the hitting set
existence problem for radius so for the
orthogonal vectors problem it's an
existing cyst is there a vector a and is
there a vector and B such that this
property holds the hitting set existence
problem on the other hand says does
there exist the vector in a such that
for all vectors in B we have a certain
property and yeah so the next slide
explains is quite well so how do we get
from these hardness conjectures to lower
bounds for radius in diameter and so for
this slide I'll show you how you can
reduce the orthogonal vectors problem to
a diameter ish looking graph so I've
written the problem up there again but
the key idea is we'll make a set of
nodes on the left corresponding to list
a each note on the left will represent
one of the vectors from this day and
we'll do the same thing for this be on
the right hand side of this graph and
then finally the center of the graph
will have one node for each one of the C
log n coordinates and then we simply
hook up two nodes if the vector here has
this coordinate on so if it's on we'll
draw an edge and so what does it mean
for a pair to be orthogonal so if a pair
is not orthogonal then
they have a coordinate where they share
a one in other words so if if there's
some vector here and some vector here
and they actually are orthogonal
there'll be a two-hot path going between
the two and if they're not orthogonal
there won't be any two iPads because
they won't share any of the coordinates
in common and you can kind of get a
sense of why this leads to a diameter
looking graph so we aren't quite a damn
it yet we have to take a few more steps
to get to any diameter problem but the
key idea is that whether there's an
orthogonal pair or not kind of
determines whether the diameter when you
only consider endpoints and a and
endpoints in b is two or three in this
graph when we had a few widgets okay
cool so how are these conjectures
related and how believable is the
hitting set existence conjecture so like
I said orthogonal vectors we use it to
show our diameter balance and we use
hitting set show radius downs Ryan
showed in 2004 that Seth implies
orthogonal vectors and we actually show
the strange result that hitting set
existence implies orthogonal vectors
which is slightly counterintuitive so if
you call a hitting set was the exists
for all version of the problem and it
has an alternating quantifier so you
kind of expect the problem to be more
difficult than the exists exists version
but this reduction that we've shown our
paper actually proves that the other way
around is true the exists exists problem
is harder than this is for all and it
can be used to solve the exists for all
problem yeah okay so i will briefly go
over our results on how well the radius
in diameter can be approximated in truly
sub quadratic time oh and we say sparse
graphs in the title of this talk because
we care about the case where m equals n
as for most of these results relevant
because we're figuring out when n
squared is the right bound so I guess
the inspiring paper for this work was
the one by Roddy and Virginia in 2013
where they use orthogonal vectors to
show that three halves is the right
answer for undirected diameter and
X diameter and then so this is n to the
roughly n to the 1.5 in a sparse graph
so what we do is we extend these results
to weighted setting so like I said the
minimum eccentricity problems are rather
difficult one interesting case for them
is the case of DAGs so on a dag minimum
eccentricity is the only non trivial
definition of eccentricity for
everything else because the distances
between u and v are always at least
infinity in one of the two directions
all the problems become trivial somme in
diameter remains hard even for dags and
then for round trip diameter so when I
say metric for the algorithm that just
means that because because the the
centricity obeys the triangle inequality
if you just any if you just pick any
point it serves as a two approximation
for the diameter and we managed to prove
of three halves bound from orthogonal
vectors but there's still a bit of a gap
so our results various are all new
because we're introducing the hitting
set conjecture we managed to show that
the algorithm for undirected radius
actually turns out to be tight under
this new conjecture but surprisingly we
actually find that a lot of other
algorithms are tight and not even at
three halves these other items were
tight at two so for source radius we
present a two approximation algorithm
and this one's not trivial because if
you think about it source radius is not
a metric so just because there's a
center that can reach everything quickly
doesn't mean if I pick an arbitrary node
I can get to the center and then get to
any other node quickly so we we spend a
bit of work proving a two bound and then
we also show a to lower bound from the
hitting set conjecture max radius we
show that the met the knife metric using
algorithm is tight and min radius is
still quite difficult although we get
just a three-to-two gap on DAGs and then
we show that the metric case for round
trip radius is tight and if you're
interested in graph algorithms for
radius and diameter you should
definitely take a look at the paper to
see how we do these but like I said for
this talk I really want to focus on our
fixed parameters sub or attic algorithms
so what does this mean so this is a new
framework called fixed parameter
tractable and P and I guess the basic
idea is that typically when you think
about primaries complexity you want to
know what problems can be solved in F of
K times poly end time and then sample k
in this case are like what is the size
of your clique or what is the clause
size of your set instance or what is the
tree with of your graph and typically
this is applied to NP problems it
doesn't make sense for problems in P
because for any parameter there by
definition fpt you just use the same
algorithm and you ignore the parameter
but a more fine-grain approach would be
to pin down what the correct exponent on
the running times in which case pulling
out this F of K factor sometimes does
matter maybe an algorithm is you know in
this case like maybe you think it should
take n squared time but if you pull out
F of K for the right choice of parameter
K you can beat n squared time so what is
the right exponent and for our
particular problems the natural question
is can reduce damage we solved when we
focus on tree with in truly sub
quadratic time after pulling out true
with and what functions of K do we need
yeah so Jenna palomares eosin
Niedermayer also propose an approach
independently this approach in the same
year but their paper only shows upper
bounds on our work both shows upper
bound and upper bound and the lower
bound and so it kind of shows we have
all the tools we need to kind of pin
down the correct running times and this
is pretty exciting new field some recent
results that have followed foamin at all
study max flow parametrized by tree with
and many other problems and they show
roughly linear time algorithms for them
and then a mirror and some other
co-authors also study the subtree
isomorphism problem and in this case the
parameter is the depth of the trees so
these are very recent results that have
come after this work
well and so the parameter we use is true
with I won't go too much in detail
because it was already covered in the
boot camp but just a very very brief
review of the definition it's the
parameterization of under of undirected
graphs problems and the kind of tries to
capture when a graph is very close to a
tree so tree sub tree with one and the
complete graph has tree with n minus 1
so the fundamental take away from true
with is if your graph problem is easy on
trees maybe it's FP t with respect to
true with and it turns out radius and
diameter are very easy on trees although
it's not that obvious if you just try to
do it at first glance so the algorithm
for diameter is folklore but it goes as
follows you start at any vertex V inside
the graph and you choose the you find
the furthest vertex from it and we claim
that that has to be one of the end
points of the diameter and then you can
just search from the furthest vertex for
that for the other end point and you
will know the diameter of the graph and
kind of the reason why this is true is
if the diameter doesn't involve you as
one of the endpoints and then you can
find a longer path inside the graph
because inside the tree there's really
only one path between two notes and then
you get radius for free after you solve
that just from the observation that the
diameter has to fall pretty closely
between to our minus one and two are so
for example if the diameters five you
know the radius has to just be three at
the diameter is 6 the radius still has
to be three so like you can just convert
the diameter are going to radius
algorithm with this equation cool so
what do we do for true with well we
solve all versions in 22 the order k log
k plus a little more than linear time
and we also show that so we solve all of
the versions we presented exactly in
that time so including the direction
versions and by true with on directed
graphs we actually mean the true width
of the underlying undirected graph so if
you just undirected edge and you measure
the truth of that graph and we also show
that even approximating any better than
1.5 into the little of K and truly
sub-project
time woodruff you the appropriate
hardness conjecture so if you did for a
radius problem you would violate the
hitting site conjecture and if you did
it for a diameter problem you would
violate the orthogonal vectors
conjecture and I will go more into the
algorithms in this talk but the lower
bound idea comes basically we take the
constructions that we've been using to
prove our previous quadratic bounds and
we implement them with a graph where the
tree with is small and in this paper
it's actually pretty easy because as is
like I think it's pretty commonly known
if you remove one node then you lower
the truth by most one and as you can see
in the construction if you just remove
all the nodes in the center there's only
C log n of them so and then disconnected
graph will just have constant tree with
cool so I'll be covering how we get this
runtime next so what is our gimmick
strategy so we will solve both radius
and diameter and more by computing the
eccentricity of every single node in the
entire graph and the only way we will be
using tree with is by the reduction to
the following problem so instead of a
general graph will be using the fact
that it has small tree with in order to
kind of sub divide it into two problems
so they'll be notes that on the left a
note set on the right and the only way
to get between these two is the K nodes
in the center so this this goes with
truth concepts like portable or
separator and you can see the tree with
K determines the size of the nodes in
the middle that we have to deal with and
the other property of truth that this
the truth gives us is that the left hand
side and the right hand side are rather
balanced so we will be recursive on this
cool so like I said our strategy will be
recursive s to find all the e centricity
within s and will be recursing on the
right-hand side as well and then we'll
just straight out run Dijkstra from the
KA nodes and center because there's only
a constant number of them or K Avila and
then the only thing the only bit of
information really missing in order to
fully figure out all these centricity is
given a node on the left hand side so I
give you a note on the left hand side
what's the furthest node on the right
hand side I already already know the
furthest node on the left hand side
I via the recursive call and I already
know the furthest note in the middle
because i have a Dykstra call from the
middle nodes alright so we now have the
following three layered problem so like
I said feature on the left what's the
furthest note on the right and we know
it has to go through one of the nodes in
the middle so we can just write down our
Dykstra distances has waited edges and
all of the distances we care about are
only two hot pads inside of this graph
so in order to get from a inside capital
a to its furthest node here we have to
go through one of these K nodes in the
middle so I have the distances from k
both to and from every other node in the
graph so it's just a two-hot paths at
this point okay so I just want to make a
note right here that if k is equal to 1
which happens only when the graph is a
tree this problem is very simple so the
reason is the answer is the same for
every node a on the left you just look
at the furthest node see from the one
single solitary middle node B and that
will be the furthest note from every
node in a so if k equals 1 it's very
easy and then we'll kind of extend that
intuition for K equals 2 so what happens
when K equals 2 so there's two nodes in
the center of our graph there's be one
and there's be too and suppose we are
processing and we find some way and we
want to know the answer for that a so
all the a really gives us is the disc
its distance the to be one and its
distance to be too and sort of the
natural question is which nodes in see
is that the right answer to go through
b1 and out of all those nodes which one
is the farthest from b1 because that's
the one we actually want to use for a
going through be one and then by
symmetry we can do the same thing for b2
and we would have the correct
eccentricity for a sew in equation form
this is a b1 is the optimal portal node
for a node see only if this equation
holds so the path go
through be one to see is better than the
path going through be two to get to see
and then using a pretty standard
rearrangement trick when you're trying
to make comparisons like this the
left-hand side is only the dependent on
a and the right-hand side is essentially
only dependent on C so remember we're
given these at the moment but we could
pre process these and that's the key
idea of the algorithm so the right hand
side can be pre computed ahead of time
so for every node in C will associate
with it well we will associate it with a
point on a line and it will be located
at this coordinate then when we get an A
inside the left set we care about all
the points on the line that are to the
right of this coordinate and then out of
all those points we just want to know
the one that is farthest from b1 because
that's the one that will be used if we
use any node that goes through be one so
like I said in this interval which point
is the furthest from b1 and if you're
familiar with some data structures this
is just data structure problem you can
solve it for example with a binary index
tree but in general when we have a
larger k we will have K minus 1
coordinates and it becomes the K minus 1
dimensional orthogonal range searching
problem so you're essentially given the
K minus 1 dimensional analogue of an
axis aligned rectangle and you want to
know what's the biggest point inside of
this like hyper rectangle and existing
data structures can solve it in n to the
log K minus 2n so sort of one log faster
than you would expect and then log to
the K minus 2n query time but we want to
make inquiries because we want to query
every point in a so our runtime is just
so we will we will make one of these
data structures for every point in the
middle set B and then we'll make n
queries to each data structure and so
that will cost k n log K minus 2 to the
N and then we have to recurse on the
left and right
and the last thing was the Dykstra call
but that's dominated by the first term
so I haven't written it down and then if
you kind of solve this and you use the
fact that the two sides were actually
balanced it turns out you pick up the
factor K because they're not completely
balanced they can be off by a factor of
K is the way the proof goes and you pick
up the log from the current but you get
this runtime and then I guess the
homework exercise is use standard fixed
parameter tractable analysis to show
that this is dominated by the original
fbt time I wrote at the beginning cool
yes so some open questions so there was
a there was an approximation gap for
truly sub quadratic algorithms for
round-trip diameter and there was an
upper bound of two which is just a
metric case and we show three halves is
their way to close this gap and then
perhaps more interestingly for the fixed
parameter side there's quite an
interesting gap between this upper bound
and this lower bound so first of all
this term compared to the little o of K
term this gap is o of is it possible to
like narrow to improve this all the way
down to 0 of K and it might be necessary
there's also a gap between this and this
because this is almost one and that's
almost too so maybe you can improve this
if you increase this one a little bit
and the other no I want to make is our
upper bound was exact and this lower
bound even applies to anything up two or
three halves approximation yeah I think
that's actually a really interesting
question and then finally a a challenge
as most speakers have done is like what
happens if you take the FP T&P framework
and you apply it to your favorite
problem in p can you say anything about
how much the running time improves when
you're allowed to characterized by a
parameter
any questions yes more like your
comments on quite sure that the
algorithm for that there is an algorithm
for diameter that runs in time 2 to the
K times look Delta with dell times the
diameter x m ok it's delta in the
exponent or ok i see a time for the
other sorry i can replace you lost a
bionic elta sometimes better i see if
the damage is constant I because then I
see ya that means that you'll know about
this types those cases in which the
diameter is 2 or 3 as it is in all your
lower buns Yeah right ok those cases the
lower bound is baby answer is so
restricted to of the regime where the
diameter is 2 or 3 or 15 or your
favorite constant 2 to the K times n is
the right answer which is kind of leader
ya understand the round trip diameter in
this regime so should the directive ramp
diameter for this are you talking about
the fut version I am I think this is the
same gap by because this algorithm also
holds and the lower bound for rent robe
diameter goes to tree with so we get
these two but there's still the gap yeah
we have our algorithm runs for all the
directed variants even min
well so two comes one as a I think it's
really nice what you did here I think
taking credit for being doing fpt on
phenomenal time problem i'm sure that
has been not i mean people apt have
always tried to reduce complexity in the
polynomial and all this kind of stuff
I'm just taking that this is I just
saying it's not a completely new thing I
thing to apply apt to poonam real time
that's all I think we actually didn't
know of any previous work that I've done
it but maybe it easily yeah it's okay
you can think of some sense
what's new is that where chidiya to
worry about enter the two minus epsilon
right yeah lowering actually the only
one time when we know that under some
plausible assumption and squared is the
best then our happens when you so this
thing otherwise